okay well thank you everyone for coming
always good to see a nice nice big
turnout I think many of you in the room
know our speaker Melissa Handel who is a
member of our faculty and who now splits
her time between here and lovely
Corvallis Oregon State University and
she lives down that way and so and also
has had some great opportunities there
but melissa has been a an excellent
contributor to our faculty teaching and
and mentoring students and and bringing
in research projects that a number of
the faculty and hopefully over time
students and fellows will be involved
with called the Center for data to
health
Melissa's main research focus is on
ontologies and data almost anything
having to do with biomedical data and
ontology says Melissa's fingerprints on
so she's very well known nationally so
it's an honor for us to have her on our
faculty even though she's known around
the world for her work and has tons of
collaborators she actually is a has
spent a good part of her life in Oregon
she did her undergraduate at Reed went
off and got a PhD at University of
Wisconsin in neuroscience and then came
back and did a postdoc first at Oregon
State then U of O and I came to OHSU
when our library was a recipient of was
it the vivo project that I brought you
here yeah and and then she joined our
faculty and has been involved in a
number of projects some of the data
science education work that we've done
so it's been a real thrill I could
probably go on and on for like 10 or 20
minutes but you all came to see her talk
so I will turn it over to Melissa just
reminding anyone who's watching by
stream
if you do want to ask a question tweet
with the hashtag demise Kampf DMI Cee
conf and we'll try to work those
questions in so take it away thanks Bill
well it's obviously a real pleasure for
me to be here and talk about some of the
things I care about the most with you
all many of you participated in various
bits and pieces of some of what I'm
going to talk about but yeah it's really
really a special pleasure for me to be
here today so hey I'm gonna talk about
maybe what I think is a little bit less
traditional in this context but I
thought it would be really useful
especially for our students to really
think about the impact of how what we do
individually or even in our small group
projects really can impact how the world
reuses our work and how we interact in
this greater ecosystem of data and so
I'm going to talk up today the title is
the yellow brick road of open science
and what are really the barriers to the
data that we generate and really in a
bucket for gain sort of way you know add
value to in process and curate and then
hand off to the next person for their
usage and when we think about
bioinformatics pipelines there's you
know kind of an unsung you know army of
bio curators and ontology that are
helping to organize that information
that we we really forget about the
provenance of where that that's
happening and how that's happening and
so this is really sort of meant to be a
little bit of an eye-opener about some
of those those challenges so that we can
prospectively continue to do better so
the cost of genome sequencing has
dropped dramatically and so of course
you know the the dream is what we're
gonna have precision medicine now aren't
we
but the reality is is that in how we go
about interpreting it is really the
bottleneck and there and the real
expense and the real challenge at this
point so so I just wanted to tell a
little story I'm not mostly going to not
talk about my actual research today but
rather but this is just a story from a
research so this is Jessica jessica has
a rare condition which causes epilepsy
and affects her her movement and she has
significant developmental delay this
this patient had a lot of different a
battery of genetic testing and what you
know what we this she's a patient in the
genomics England cohort and we we
actually solved her case using some of
the approaches that I'm gonna talk a
little bit about but but to solve her
case to understand what her genetic
variation is requires combining her
genome with a whole lot of other data
that comes from many different places as
well as from model organisms so we call
this this challenge the chasm of
semantic despair that's me at the bottom
of the chasm and really what the
challenge is is that over there on the
right we might have clinical measures
for Jessica might understand how to
measure her developmental delay we might
have laboratory values for her metabolic
state but fundamentally those clinical
data are not very interactive you know
genomics proteomics metabolic pathway
modeling and all these kinds of things
and so one of the big goals is to
develop ways to make clinical data on
basic research data talk to each other
so that we can tap into this information
for a rare disease patient like Jessica
where we don't actually know anything
from the clinical community about her
particular disorder so Jessica actually
had her whole exome X actually a whole
genome and she had 6 million variants
from the reference genome in her genome
and over 600 and over 600,000 of those
were rare variants so that's like the
corpus of what could be causal for her
for her disease we filtered that that
down based on a number of algorithms
that predict passage in this city and
changes to protein so looking for stops
in the protein or things that would
change conformational changes and we get
down to 2800 and then we look at the
genetics and we get down to 67 and using
the data from the basic research
community we were able to go from 67
which would take a purse
manual interpretation many many weeks to
go through to really figure out what the
similarity was to known model organisms
or protein interaction partners to only
one by using that data on this child so
always makes me cry this is like a happy
kid now because she has she's treated
with diet so it's really the power of
that that we're after so this is the
world that we live in in order to try to
make those cases those wonderful success
stories happen so we have information
coming from human disease phenotype
resources which is largely still the
only thing that clinicians tap into but
there's this whole wealth of model
organism databases and gene expression
pathway databases and functional
databases and microbiome databases and
they multiply daily in the nucleic acids
research a special issue a lot of
resources will take data and try to
aggregate it and just mash it all into
one place and say okay look what can
make all this data available you can
search it here but when you do that you
lose all those special connections that
we have that tell us about the knowledge
and what we really want is we want to
have things stay linked we want them to
be we want to understand what the
relationship is between variants and a
protein interaction partner or between a
disease and a phenotype so this means
that the date of brick road is a means
not the destination and the reason I say
that is because how many of you have
heard of fair data principles so
probably about half so findable
accessible interoperable and reusable
well there's a certain amount of like
it's jumped the shark kind of notion
with regard to fair because at the end
of the day it's really the our that we
care the most about and many of these
contexts so in order to make the are
really make the data really reusable the
three challenges that I'm really going
to focus on today are traceable
licensing and connected which are
fundamental to the kinds of biology that
we want to do so that's really where
we're at just really trying to focus on
that in or out
ability and reusability and that
requires semantic data integration so
just a little bit more about each of
these principles so traceable is all
about the evidence the provenance and
the attribution knowing who that
bucket-brigade member was that did that
curation and can you count on them
knowing so a clinician can know where
the data came from so they can know if
it's you know of high value or low value
to their interpretation that they're
making for their genomic candidate
licensing that the licensing for the
data can actually that is clearly stated
comprehensive and not negotiated
accessible that you avoid restrictions
of reuse and avoids restrictions on who
may reuse we're going to come back to
this quite a lot and Robin in our
audience has helped really help lead
this effort and then connected
identifier is having you know really
good identifier hygiene data models
ontology zand concept alignment and
clinical data elements that allow us to
cross that chasm of semantic despair so
identifiers are the invisible bedrock of
scientific inquiry the more complex the
question the more reliance that you need
to have on identifiers hygiene so if all
we care about is what we can just have
identifier x' but if we want to know
something about how many or why or how
we really under need to understand what
those identifiers x' mean in different
contexts what's the metadata what's the
data model what's the context for those
those links that that we want to keep
when we integrate data so equivalence
and synonyms are in the eye of the
beholder and not always what they seem
so this is an example for the disease
known as ehlers-danlos syndrome and it's
a complex and poorly understood disease
that is known by as many as 40 different
synonyms from different database
resources and it's listed in 15
different disease vocabularies all of
which mapped to each other
right and so how many of you in this
room have combined two data sets that
had map identifiers mappings and they
didn't line up in the two directions
okay it's like half of you right this is
like a fundamental problem in biology
well if you're a clinician and you want
to diagnose your patient with EDS but
your different databases call it
something different and have different
definitions for it how
the world are we supposed to solve a
rare disease patients diagnosis if we
can't even agree on what the definition
is so this may seem very pedantic but
but identification is the foundation to
ask very simple questions like how many
people in Oregon have been diagnosed
with ehlers-danlos syndrome we don't
know the answer to this question even to
this day what is the collective cost of
care of these persons what are the most
cost effective interventions are there
any evidence that these patients with
that are yet to be diagnosed with this
syndrome and how do we reveal those and
and Bill's done some interesting work in
this area as well as trying to reveal
candidates for a diagnosis just from the
underlying data so the identify are
cleaning is a shared pain point and a
huge time sink but there's not really
good ways of sharing the outcomes of our
identifier cleaning so for example let's
say I actually went through and
conceptually aligned every single
ehlers-danlos disease representation
from every single source how do I
actually share that back so that
somebody else can use it and the reality
is there's not a very good way and I
like to joke that the online Mendelian
inheritance and Man database which has
some particular funkiness ease with its
identifiers has probably had the same
script written to clean the identifiers
in the same way but it must be over
10,000 people by now right
the same script right we're just not
good at sharing how we how we munge that
and unless you can get the source to fix
it but you can't in that case you're
you're challenged to just to just you
know go on as we are so so that's a real
problem this is just an example of what
we can do when we actually have the
right alignments and the and the right
integration so this is from a project
called the MCATs biomedical data
translator which really tries to align
knowledge that's represented in graphs
and graph types of operations and
analytics and combine them into many
different workflows so it's really
developing a workflow language for
combining knowledge information sources
from hundreds of different resources and
so this is just a snippet of some of
that so if you can take from the Pharos
source you have drug to target
associations so you have disease drug
target and you can see some identifiers
there IDG Campbell Pharaohs we have
react 'm has
argit's pathways so we can know that a
drug target is related to a pathway in
clinvar we have disease two variants so
variants are associated with diseases or
phenotypes we have those but they're
using a different terminology and over
here and the database that I work on the
monarch we have phenotypes of diseases
and we use the human phenotype ontology
to associate it with our disease
representation Fanconi anemia so you can
see the challenge but you can also see
how if you start to get really strong
alignment those identifiers the
capability of finding a drug target for
a very rare disease starts to become
really apparent so what you need to do
with the data though depends on the
integration approach so you know if we
if we really you know download
everything the burdens on the integrator
there's less coordination needed
upstream if we really want to have like
you know the subway map which is more
like the translator the burden becomes
more on the provider getting those
sources to actually have better
identifier hygiene have better change
management have better documentation
about their identifiers how their
provision and what they mean in
different contexts so just want to talk
a little bit about equivalency so one of
the challenges in aligning these
knowledge is just fundamentally
understanding what is the same in two
different places so you know we might
have two different equivalent
identifiers for the same record that
have and to know that they're the same
record is not always trivial we might
have surrogacy or distribution so
there's a European distribution of
MEDLINE for example versus one here in
the US we have versioning and content
evolution so you know conceptually what
we define is a gene today is not at all
the same as what it was even ten years
ago and so there's this conceptual drift
and so you know you might find things
categorized as genes that really don't
meet that current standard anymore we
have related real world concepts so
chirality how do two chiral molecules
you know relate to a parent more generic
form that might be represented in a
different database equivalent real-world
concepts that you
no we're we just haven't determined the
equivalency yet you know we saw this
with Fanconi anemia and braca based
breast cancer right so with that same
gene turned out to be the underlying
causal gene for those two different
diseases and then overlapping records
that that chain that referenced the same
identifier so again this is this like
you know everybody Maps to everybody
else but they all do it differently and
they all those mappings mean something
different when you combine them all
together computationally you end up with
cycles so you can't perform inference
with cycles and the inability like the
ehlers-danlos example to actually make
diagnosis and with that example and if
you want to look at more examples
there's a bitly there so because we're
actually that nerdy we wrote a community
best practices guide to identify our
hygiene there's also a really fun blog
that's been posted on the plus bio about
this if you're interested so identify
errs for the 21st century how to design
provision and reuse persistent
identifiers to maximize utility and
impact of life science data and it was a
three year effort from many community
members from different contexts so it's
there's some really good guidance for if
you if you are a identifier Minter
please read this paper I'd love to have
your comments too okay so I'm going to
move on to a little bit about data you
know licensing and the ability to reuse
and redistribute licensing so whether
the data is actually open or closed for
reuse is actually impossible to know
until you try and many of us take data
from databases and do stuff with it and
do analyses and then we publish our
results but if you actually want to
combine those resources and redistribute
them legally that's a different problem
so when we build our diagnostic tools we
need to redistribute to the clinicians
that meet the tools well when you go
back and look under the hood many of
these resources are not it's not so easy
to tell which ones are open for
redistribution and which ones are not
so this really started as part of our
work on the monarch initiative project
which is the one that builds the
diagnostic tools are we integrate all
this data from all these places using
ontology x' but what that really means
is we have this incredible licensing
burden so over here on the right are
just some of the resources that we
integrate data from and these are these
are our institutions and so for every
source that we integrate there's a
pairwise relationship legally that has
to be realized in order for us to get
legal approval to redistribute and some
of these resources are also distributed
and I'm not even showing that right so
you can see that the legal burden is
just insane and in fact in three years
here at OHSU I have no data sources
licensed in or out so it's actually
really challenging to overcome those
those burdens so and just because we're
gonna also talk about attribution in a
minute in academia data licensing is a
credit hack and a common pain point so
why do these resources have these
restrictive licenses it's so they can
get attribution so they can tell their
funding agency that they're valuable
right it's it's a way of sort of just
you know making things freely available
makes it harder to justify if you don't
know who's using your work you know
you're it's really an attribution hack
so I love this quote from Ann carpenter
I would be so happy to never wrangle
another legal agreement in my entire
life seven of the emails preventing
inbox zero involve pestering lawyers
just to be able to work with scientists
elsewhere can we please please have a
thingy that the entire universe agrees
on so we're working on the thingy but
first let's talk a little bit about
attribution because that really impacts
what the thingy can actually be so you
know there's many different definitions
of attribution if you go to Wikipedia
but they all essentially you know
involve you know providing attribution
to a person or context for information
and the source of that information so we
have this challenge in in science of you
know first off their last author the
tribution statements that you make and
your your journal
do you conclude an author if they
provided a page for service through a
core services facility I take a very
wide view on attribution that everybody
should be included and in some cases it
just takes a lot of effort to get
something done so here's a paper that
has over a thousand authors on it when
they you know for this Drosophila
genomic paper and so this is the the
world we live in well what did all these
people actually do the other problem
that we know is that in our world and
especially worlds like the work that you
all do is that a lot of the kinds of
contributions that we make don't
necessarily end up in manuscripts not at
all there's a huge amount of science
that never gets published in a
manuscript it gets published on github
or clinical instruments or many other
kinds of types of things and this was
done some time ago by Nicole vasilevsky
and our colleague Dave Eichmann and
Nicole is also a here indie mice that
you know where we basically got all of
the big data to knowledge awardees
during a funding period of three years
and because NIH couldn't track all the
key personnel and give them to us from
their database we emailed them all and
found out who were all the key personnel
on all the big data to knowledge grants
at NIH and what roles did they have and
then we did a social network analysis
just looking at co-authorship and what
we found was that more than 20% of these
key personnel were not even writing
publications so 20% of the workforce
that's funded as key personnel on the
big data to knowledge program are doing
other things they're writing code and
other things so we want to we want to
provide ways of attributing those types
of contributions so I wanted to provide
a little example and this is my own
personal example and I have no hard
feelings about this example but it's
just the reality of the world and how we
can all help each other especially in
the informatics community to attribute
people in the many different contexts
that that that we live in ways that are
innovative and you know really speak to
the types of contributions that we all
do and informatics so this is another
example from my rare disease
this was a patient at the undiagnosed
disease program at NIH numbered to 540
and in this case we actually did that
same kind of analysis where we used all
these different biomedical resources to
you know help make a diagnosis for this
family and this involved information
data that was from a mouse that was
created by Johannes and then I created I
curated the information from the patient
so I went through all the patients and
medical records and captured
semantically all their phenotypes and
all the information about their lab
tests and the like and then we'll
basically did the analytics where he
took information from the basic
resources which included that stim one
Mouse as well as all of my curated data
and he used that to generate a dataset
for prioritized variants for this family
and then Tom was that was the clinician
responsible for this patient and Tom
published a paper about this diagnosis
and Tom explicitly credited will as an
author but not me or Hannes and so
here's the graph and and so you can kind
of totally you can see it's a little
small but there's the publication up
there and the publication is attributed
to Tom who's an orange and there's an
author role in a date and Tom's also
attributed to having made the diagnosis
and so you can see that clinician role
and attribution there and the diagnosis
dependent on that dataset that was made
by will so he has a variant analysis
role here and that depends upon two
things the Yohannes is Mouse up there
and my curation work over here but if
you have a graph of all of this you can
actually infer that I contributed and
Johannes contributed into that paper
right even though we're not explicitly
credited on the paper the reality is
though what do we really care about here
do we care about the paper no we care
about the diagnosis wouldn't the patient
like to know who all of army of people
that actually contributed to their
diagnosis I think that's where we really
want to be so this is actually the all
the people that contributed to that
particular diagnosis I actually went
through the our entire workflow system
and found every
person that that contributed to that to
that diagnosis unfortunately this family
was not interested in due to religious
reasons and sharing their this story so
I picked the wrong family for writing a
paper but in any case the goal is the
ultimate goal is to reward reusability
we have to clarify the importance and
practice of attribution across the
translational work force of all the
people that contribute in all the ways
that they that they contribute okay so
now you got the story about attribution
we're going to talk about licensing
because you know now that attribution is
really a licensing hack so and this is a
work that was led by Robin and myself
and others in our group and you can find
out more information about this work at
reusable data org and we have a paper
that should be out any day now and
there's a preprint that's up there but
basically this data shows for 56
different databases that with a very
robust set of metrics that you know
roughly only 20 out of the 56 had
clearly stated licenses you know you can
see that you know fairly a little bit
larger or at least comprehensive and
didn't require a negotiation finding the
license isn't always a given and then of
course the you get out here there are
less that don't have restrictions on
either the kind of reefs or may reduce
the data so also if you look at the
license categories you can see that you
know there are a fair number that are
permissive and don't require legal
intervention but basically anything
that's not that requires some kind of
terms or legal intervention or
understanding and there's a lot of you
know kind of non-standard licenses as
well and every one of those requires a
special legal attention so this has
major implications about which data can
then be matched up and redistributed so
over there up on the right here you can
see a permissively license data is like
a universal donor it doesn't get back
much back from the more restrictive lis
license data but restrictive lis license
data can only be combined with for Mis
we license data so you can see that Lake
it gets really challenging and these are
all our sources that when you want to
redistribute you can really only
redistribute the slices that meet the
most permissive license and as it turns
out some of them were severe cases are
actually from NIH itself because they
have row-level licensing for
contributions to places like clinvar
which has actually recently been changed
in part due to our work here so just a
little bit about University licenses so
the technology transfer offices
generally do not readily share data or
related software under non-commercial
licenses they do not allow rapid data
aggregation they do not protect
commercial licensing royalty streams and
they safeguard provenance of research
data but why don't they do this it's too
many writes data data rights holders
universities preventing the use of data
sets making data integration impractical
every University wants to protect the IP
that we have in our data which is
counterproductive for us smashing it up
and redistributing it so we have this
tension so I wanted to talk about that
tension so how many of you heard of the
tragedy of the Commons all right good so
this is a graph of overfishing of
Atlantic cod and you can you can see
that basically you know we if we if we
overuse a resource we don't have it
anymore
right so that's that's really one of the
takeaways there and then we have the
anti Commons the original robber barons
over privatization and gauntlets of tool
tollbooths meant that trade basically
ceased the further down the river you
went and this is actually one of the
castles that took tolls on the on that
those trade routes back in the day so
beautiful castle so here's here's the
actual story so if we if we think about
so people say you must not be an open
science enthusiast if you don't want to
make everything Creative Commons type-0
which basically means free for anybody
under any circumstances and that would
be fully open access over here and so
that's not really true on the other hand
what technology transfer offices want is
over here and that means you can't we
have to reinvent the wheel every single
time to get data because
can't actually combine things but we
really want to be the zone of
cooperative and market-based solutions
is really over here and this is they
call the wealth of the Commons so we
need solutions that provide the
attribution but but also provide the
ability to freely redistribute under
those licensing terms and I actually
think that we don't actually have a good
license for data to date and this is
just an example of what some of those
standard licenses are from Creative
Commons so you can see CC you know zero
lets you copy and publish use
commercially modify adapt change the
license publish without attribution and
as you get down here to more restrictive
ones you know you have attribution
non-commercial no derivatives and you'd
think you know okay maybe it's really
simple we'll just go with CC buy and
maybe that solves the problem but the
problem is is that CC buy just says you
just have to have attribution but
there's two problems with that one is
that the attribution has to be
computable so if I've got data that's
been mashed up and then I smashed it up
again that license have to flow with the
data so I have but attribution is an
additional requirement computationally
that I have to track and when I when the
contributions are made by individuals on
every edge in the graph that's a whole
lot of data that has to come along for
in terms of licenses so there's a burden
of having CC by but if we go back to CC
0 we're back we're back over here where
we we're going to have overfishing right
so the other thing is is that it's not
always so easy so on some of our work
for example on one of our ontology x' we
have a custom license that has a you
know CC by no derivative type license
and the reason is because we don't want
people to take our data standard and
make derivation z' of it and not give it
back to the core because it's used for
rare disease diagnosis so if companies
go and take it and make their own
derivatives and don't give back to the
core we're actually less able to solve
more patient's cases worldwide and so
it's an ethical reason for actually
having no derivations but that's of
course not considered open science
either so
anyway I probably running out of time
how am i doing for time I'm fine okay
great so okay so why not cc0 then so
pros is that anything is better than
gridlock it's very quick and easy to
implement it's digital it's digital data
in the Commons it's inexhaustible cannot
be overused currently supported by the
Creative Commons initiatives we have a
standard license for it and NIH
tentatively supports it for biomedical
data the cons are that it doesn't
address software licensing so data
without related software often doesn't
have the same value or it's otherwise
inaccessible and it's the bado lacked
implicitly protect software against
patent rights but not data we also lose
provenance and on the research data as I
mentioned that provenance and
attribution is really important for
knowing how to justify whether or not
that data is like important for the
clinical use that you have so if we go
of cc0 we're going to lose a lot of that
really important extra information that
comes along with the attribution and the
provenance we abolish commercial royalty
streams on data sets we we have a real
sustainability issue if everybody makes
things CC 0 that means that our taxpayer
dollars have to continue to fund those
resources through NIH and other other
funding means right so there's not
really a built-in sustainability of
vehicle and in that context and it
doesn't solve the problem of various
rights holders retaining their
copyrights in their database submission
so we have to you know you know NIH can
say you know clinvar CC 0 but the actual
row level contribution still say those
copyright owners are the rows that of
the submission so they have just changed
that but you know that's a problem still
in a number of other databases so maybe
we need a new Goldilocks commons license
for data and i also have this idea
around a data trust and I'd love to hear
what what people's thoughts are on this
so a new universal license would be
similar to a CC buy so attribution
non-commercial share-alike license with
no legal renegotiation required and all
universities would join a club to have
this similar to what we've done for the
universal
mbta which is so that we can transfer
material between universities so it used
to be that we had a similar problem for
when I wanted to send a mouse or an
antibody from one institution to another
because we would have to get legal
intervention to make an agreements
because that's I pee from that
institution and so now because of the
universal MBTA all the universities have
joined the club there's no legal
intervention now required so we need
something like that for for data and we
have a committee that's that's started
for the association of university
technology managers autumn that's going
to be working on this problem so the
proposal I have is that we actually have
something called a data trust which
could include some kind of nonprofit
entity for organizations that join the
club and that the revenue would be
distributed so we would have the
commercial commercial organizations
could pay some kind of licensing fee or
there could be a you know some peruse
and you could come up with a number of
different models where you would get
some kind of revenue from commercial
users but make it free for for research
and non-commercial users and that
revenue would be redistributed amongst
the participants in the trust to provide
that sustainability vehicle so we have
our integrated data commercial entities
come to us all the time and say we would
like to license your aggregated
integrated corpus of data and we say
well you've got to contact these hundred
different resources to make your own
legal agreements because we don't have
any way of doing that so this would sort
of you know help that you know the value
of that data especially in its
integrated form be a licensable entity
that could provide sustainability for
all those resources which would then
help with the attribution and provenance
because people would actually still have
all the attribution and provenance in
that context and then funding agencies
would would promote the idea of the
organization's joining the trust and so
this would this kind of a trust could
really solve the problem also of how we
actually evaluate a data resource so not
all data resources are created equal
they come and go they have different
levels of you know robustness they you
know some graduate students prod
was really great but they graduated and
they moved on and it wasn't maintained
how do we sort of provide the value
proposition and so whatever the trust
model would be for commercial licensing
it would it would actually incentivize
participants to have their data
resources be as robust as possible which
would solve that way that we share our
knowledge about how we integrate data
and our identifiers best practices and
all those kinds of things would have to
improve in order to get your you're a
larger chunk of your licensing revenue
so with all of that I just wanted to
thank all the people that that did the
work here I'd probably missed lots and
lots of people but especially Robyn for
the data licensing work all of my
colleagues in the monarch initiative but
especially Nicole and Matt who have done
a lot of the identifiers cleaning along
with Julie and Kent and lots of
different projects that we work on
really rely on good identifiers and
hopefully soon better licensing for our
data so thanks very much use the
microphones so the talk is both recorded
and people who are streaming and can
listen to it but since I have the
microphone I will ask a question I I was
recently involved in a pretty deep
discussion about and and I noticed it's
really missing from your discussion
although you get very nice comprehensive
overview but is what are the role you
know in the medical context of patients
what's the role of them and their data
and you know there's various ideas that
are kicked around that for example and
especially outside of medicine and
public health you know that people
should be able to sell their data and
that could create a wrinkle for those of
us who want to do
biomedical research with patient data so
I could go on but I wonder if you have
any thoughts on kind of where that might
all fit in and could there be impacts if
there isn't some sort of common use that
could be done you know could be
legislated or whatever egg you lated
around patient data so there's a lot of
lot of things to talk about with that so
the first one is just interoperability
for patients right so which is kind of
even just the first step and so one
thing that we've done is so like our
terminology that we use for clinical
phenotyping we've translated it into
many different languages for global use
but we've also translated it into
layperson ease so that the patient can
actually use the same identifier for the
thing that they have in a way that they
can recognize so that's I think you know
thinking about how patients just
interact with this ecosystem is one
question and that's one way that you
that we absolutely have to have in order
order for that to work is that the same
content should be able to have different
views for different contexts so patients
need to see things in a different way
than a basic science researcher or
clinician but we need to cross that
chasm of semantic despair not for just
basic science and clinical science but
also for the patient so that's one thing
the second thing I think is just as a
patient on their data and we already are
challenged even just with data use
agreements and permissions and consent
not being very computable and so you
know I like to joke that a couple years
ago I was at the doctors and there
please sign this form saying that we're
not going to share your data I'm like
okay I want to sign the form where you
share all my data and they're like well
we can't treat you because we don't have
one of those forms there's no way for me
to sign a form it says I actually want
to share all of my medical data anyway
you know so we don't really actually
give the authority to the patient to
make those decisions for themselves
right now they walk into office and the
assumption is that we should have
protect everything and then and then
even when we do we say okay for research
purposes but what does that actually
mean and and that's where I think the
patients over time need to have more we
need to have more control
all over similar to how you are on like
Facebook for example which which people
your friends your friends our friends
the public can see things we need to
have kind of different layers of
permissions and consent that can match
the different kinds of computational
usage and those those kinds of
permissions and consent if they were
more computable could be aligned with
financial sustainability kinds of
solutions so that you know similar to
new Highnesses mouse that wouldn't
Johannes like to know that his actually
good phenotyping of his mouse led to the
diagnosis of a patient but what if he
also got back you know ten dollars every
time every diagnosis was made using a
mouse what's the same thing for a
patient if they are contributing their
data
maybe there's maybe there's a data trust
that kind of function that can work for
them as well so that if they contribute
their data to research it's clear what
kind of research but then if it's used
and it's actually useful there's some
kind of you know benefit to them and
sometimes it's just a social benefit not
a financial one I'm sure Johannes
couldn't care less if he gets ten
dollars for having made this diagnosis
but he'd sure like to know that there
was a diagnosis made so I'm most
patients feel that way too so I don't
know if other people have answers to
that question I think it's a really
important one
I was wondering on your site I think it
was the second to last slide you had you
know your your trust idea and I'm like
sitting here trying to think of what
what would be like the negatives of that
and what have the doubter sort of come
to you saying oh that won't work like
what are the greatest yeah challenges do
you think to actually making that a
reality so I think there's there's a
trust issue and you know you really it
doesn't work if only two groups decide
to join the trust like you know we
really got to get everybody to try to
work together and that's never gonna
happen until the funding agencies get on
board with this idea because if if the
funding agencies still put people
through the same priming it's one thing
to fund you know hypothesis-driven
research or clinical trials but to find
the data resource production source you
know we just we have we should have
different ways of evaluating them in
different ways of supporting them that
are that are more you know built in to
incentivize their quality production and
evolution over time and those funding
strategies right now are just they just
treat them the same as as any hypothesis
driven science and until that that sort
of general notion and it's changing
there's you know I've been emailing lots
of people at NIH and meeting with them
for many years now and it's starting to
sink in and so have many others you know
so I think it's it is going to change
but we have to have the partnership of
the funding agencies and the providers
to all at least pilot something and we
could start small you know and just you
know get you know five or ten resources
to just try it together and then show
that it works and then we could grow it
from there but I think that there's the
resources themselves will never do
anything without the stick from the
funding agencies and there and then they
don't trust that their best interests
are in mind because they're so used to
being afraid of losing their funding you
know through this not very good process
of review that these types of resources
go through so I think it's it's like
that it's a little bit of a catch-22
because we need the community
to tell the funding agency that this is
how it should be but we also need the
funding agencies to sale the resources
that this is how it's going to be and
try to coordinate that cycles that
there's no cons to it it's just who's
going to get paid to do that I already
spend like one day a week on my data
licensing problems you know so there's I
we just need somebody at NIH to kind of
break the catch-22 I think yeah yeah I
think two other things that are related
to that is one which you touched on the
work that goes into taking a data set
from the point where the person who
created it can use it to the point where
other people can reuse it is it's an
extensive amount of work yeah and it can
be daunting and it's generally kind of
unrewarded work and obviously like this
exact proposal would be in some ways
generating the benefit for doing that
kind of work but it's it's non-trivial
and that's part of the
part of the problem and then the other
thing related to the the patient issue
is issues of privacy and anyone who is
working with or creating a data set
based on patient data always has these
concerns about patient privacy and
what's permit a ball and what should be
done and you know you're talking about
the fact that this consent process needs
to be computable and I know that there's
also discussion that the idea of
informed consent at its core has not
kept up pace with the way that
biological biomedical science has
developed and that something really has
to change so that there is a better
understanding between researchers and
providers and patients about what they
are actually agreeing to and that would
have the added benefit of potentially
clearing up some of these data sharing
and reuse issues but it's pretty gnarly
right now to try and wade through that
as a researcher yeah and so then that
puts the fear of God in you yeah and you
do nothing because you're too afraid to
as we all should be but yeah but it's
it's sort of a
Walker I've had literal panic attacks
about Lee yeah so do you guys feel
empowered to make good identifiers and
it's from you to all the people that
touch them I mean you saw you described
it a little bit but you know I - you
know sometimes come across those you
know papers that have a thousand authors
and you know I really wonder you know
how many people who are on that author
list actually wrote a single word in
this paper and so you know how how can
we you know and especially for academia
I mean you know for us to advance and
get credit or as you say to get credit
in making diagnosis huh how do you
envision that will happen that there are
ways to attribute contributions to these
sorts of projects well that is something
that we're working on um a couple
different things you know I think one is
we actually worked really hard not that
long ago as some people complained about
this but to get the nih biosketch format
changed so that so you know when it went
from three pages to five pages and
everybody complained because it took
them a whole day to redo their biosketch
well you can blame that partly on me but
part of the reason was so that we could
actually put non-traditional types of
contributions on there so it doesn't all
have to be published literature but it
could be a code base or a clinical
instrument or a diagnosis of a new
family of genes or you know of diseases
so you know I would urge all of you in
that context or on your CV to list all
the kinds of contributions that you make
to science I story I'll tell I was at a
rare disease foundation meeting which
was one third patients one third
clinical physicians in that field and
one third basic science researchers and
you know I we were told that we were not
allowed to take photos or tweet of any
kind at this meeting that this was a
to be a safe space for us to work on
this rare disease together and I was I
just stood up at the Town Hall at the
end and I said I'm really surprised so
the first time I had been to this
particular meeting I'm really surprised
that you guys aren't like you know
announcing to the world what you're all
doing and getting the world to work on
your rare disease why don't you know
couldn't we incentivize many more people
to help solve the problems that you have
if you you know we're we're sharing your
information about what you're doing
sharing your data sharing your
technologies and one of the more you
know senior people in the community
stood up and said but if we do that our
graduate students and postdocs won't be
able to get that cell paper that will
get them a job at Harvard and I said you
know I think that we have the potential
to change this one CV at a time right so
if you if you at Harvard only hire
people who see these have the things on
it that show that diverse kinds of
contribution that's how we're going to
change it so we all have to go back so
your homework gets to go back and fix
your CV your biosketch and make sure
there's lots of stuff on there that is
not a paper so that the world can know
that you do other things besides write
papers because I know you all do because
you're an informatics department so you
know the Noto is your friend publish
things get persistent identifiers z' for
them you know and for anyone who ends up
being on a hiring committee look for
that and value those kinds of diverse
contributions we also that's part one
part two is that we also are working on
a contribution role oncology as you
might imagine and that ontology will
have a little data model associated
which allows you to record the kinds of
contributions to any kind of entity so
if you have you know we can record
contributions to an ontology we can
record contributions to a clinical best
practice guide we can record
contributions to you know a
computational package and we can say
what were the roles that the people had
in that and that would actually allow me
to have said you know what were the
roles like all the way back to to these
guys you know what were all the roles
that that these people actually had in
that diagnosis I would be able to do
that and I could also associate that
little file with the paper so even
though they
authors on the paper so they didn't
write a word of the paper that doesn't
mean they didn't contribute to the
science right and so right now the
acknowledgements section of a paper is
really a proxy for these types of more
distant contributions but many of which
are pivotal and and and this type of
structure would actually let us include
everybody that contributed so yeah I
thought about it a little bit too much
probably yeah go ahead
so is there any conversation among the
International Committee of medical
journal editors or you know National
Library of Medicine for PubMed about
actually having the acknowledgments
field be a possible discoverable field
in a standardized way so that when
people are googling you to you know find
your you know publications in PubMed
that they find these other kind of
activities because otherwise it's just
oh they don't have very many
publications in PubMed and they don't
even get to the level of looking at your
biosketch necessarily yeah yeah
absolutely so there are conversations
going on and I know Robins had some of
these conversations too we we've
actually mined all the acknowledgments
of all the papers that are in MEDLINE we
have them all in one big database and
we've associated all of the all of those
people's names that we could with people
with orchids or other authors that are
in MEDLINE so we actually now know who
all those people were it's a little
harder to figure out what they actually
did but we do have just sentence parsing
of those phrases so it says you know you
know Melissa made a mouse right and so
Mouse would be the same sentence as
Melissa so we have those phrases parse
so we can kind of get a sense of that
we've done some classification of that
and there's been some other published
studies that have done some really
interesting classification of mining of
acknowledgments as well we actually I
did have a conversation with NLM
recently about this exact problem and
also the notion that we not just for
this purpose but for many purposes how
can the community build tools on top of
MEDLINE because MEDLINE is really a
quality collection of journals that
provide quality science we should have
the ability to build lots of different
kinds of tools on top of literature and
share those which is kind of gets back
to that sharing problem instead of
either relying solely on NLM to provide
them or you know running over here and
finding somebody's github account and
running your own thing to create more of
like a tool shed around MEDLINE and so
this is what the where the main
conversation has been is to try to think
about how do we create a community
driven tool shed for functions like this
to live on top of MEDLINE so and if
anybody wants to participate in this
effort I would love some partners so you
know yeah any other questions or
thoughts we can go around the room and
hear somebody's identify our pain story
anybody want to share the last last
thought good good identifier story
Robin shampoo library your cell one or
two floors below us can do that well
okay we're actually just about out of
time so I want to thank Melissa or
talking I'm looking for myself to
visiting Oregon State next week so cool
we're doing like reciprocal visits thank
you and you'll stick around
[Applause]